Travis Scott is fired up over rumors he
cheated on Kylie Jenner yep the rapper
is clearing the air about his
relationship with the libtech creator on
Monday Travis made one thing clear he
only has love for Stormies mom okay so
after a photo surfaced of what appeared
to be Travis cozying up to a mystery
woman he slammed one fan in the comments
writing I don't be on a balcony with no
thoughts that blame try again you trolls
me and my wifey sturdy okay how this is
really rare for Travis Scott to be
speaking out he normally keeps really
quiet about drama but when you're
breaking up a happy home or you try to
he's gonna comfort oh he is going to
shut it down and he did yup and of
course everyone knows about the
kardashian-jenner crew curse will just
leave that one there
Travis set the record straight again on
his instace Tori quote trolls always
want to create some fake to destroy real
love
I hate acknowledging but quit trying to
take joy from that's good I pray God
blocks out all evil back to celebrating
I mean there's a lot of f-bombs that he
dropped he seemed to be really upset
yeah I've got a drop of odd you got a
drop a bomb sometimes so how do you
think Travis handled the cheating rumors
I feel like he set the record straight
he made it very clear don't come for his
family and I love it and now he's
celebrating so what is he celebrating
okay so he has a lot to celebrate he's
applying to Harvard after teaching a
master class at the University he
tweeted out he's gonna he wants to go to
Harvard look at that Marines and can rap
I love it exactly and he has a real huge
milestone he hit number one on the
Billboard 200 from both his Astroworld
album and his song sicko mode so kudos
to him yeah and of course he's always
taking stormy and Kylie on tour with him
and he's spoiling their baby girl take a
look at what they said you have the
biggest album of the year and you have a
brand-new little baby girl
honey what a year for you I don't write
she saw him that story is just so
animated I never thought I can just like
love something like so hard you know
[Music]
stormy not me
stormy their own room at every venue it
seems like Travis loves hard when it
comes to all the ladies in his life and
we love that yell Kylie and Travis
sparked engagement rumors recently hm so
Kylie posted a photo of the couple with
a ring emoji at the top and true Kylie
fashioned of course people went crazy it
sent fans into a frenzy but Travis is
always calling Kylie wifey which i think
is just a phrase do you think that
they're engaged I don't but I do think
they have this really unconventional but
kind of traditional like they shoved in
with them and but I think they just are
in a really good place it seems like
both doing well professionally that's
for sure that is definitely for sure so
is marriage on the way for Travis and
Kylie let's talk about it all across
social on a scale of 1 to engage do we
think Kylie and Travis have taken the
next step in their relationship and do
you think it was necessary for Travis to
speak out about the cheating rumors at
this time let's keep the combo going
across social media yep I met Kourtney
underscore tez oh no and I met Holly
underscore Stevens until next time we've
got you covered